[Music]
20 international chess professionals
converge in st. Louis for the 2017 fall
chess classics the eighth round has come
and gone in the Fall Classic with only
one round left surprisingly there are
still a lot of players who could win
this thing it's true that Georg Meyer
and yarrow zero book lead group a and
Josh Vidal leads Group B but when you
factor in playoffs a lot of options can
be explored the fields combined have a
prize fund of $36,000 the top prize in
Group A is six grand
the top prize in Group B is four grand
the final round is set for Thursday
September 14 it starts at a special
early time of 11 a.m. Central this is to
give us extra time if we need a playoff
the playoff will occur in either field
if there is a tie for first place with
just one more day to go I'm here with
Roofing Li one of America's greatest
junior players just 15 years old but I
know you have a birthday coming up
tomorrow so we'll make sure that you get
the Happy Birthday song treatment just
like Shambhala did
[Music]
but today with the black pieces you were
able to upend Jude when Jim what did
this victory mean to you I think it was
a very happy event and a great present
for my birthday because it is my first
win in the tournament so far it has been
a rough road I mean this tournament is
very strong and you are in the top field
how does this mesh with your
expectations coming in to the entire
tournament I thought probably I should
have done better
maybe you either not have lost so many
games or won some of them well today was
a good day so let's take a look at the
game you had with when June and here I
decided my pest pun was very strong so I
played c3 I was expecting her to play
Queen d3 here and I think the game was
looking Josh because after Bishop takes
and Bishop takes e5 Queen takes Bishop
takes Knight she takes with a pond and
after rook seats you and I see pond is
more or less under control but she
played Queen d7 okay she's attacking my
knight but I can just ignore it and
played c2 and she put the rook on d3 and
here it was a pretty critical move for
me to find and I played Knight c3 and
the point is if she takes on c2 then she
loses because of my 82 and there's a
back rank checkmate and if she doesn't
do anything immediately then I'm
threatening either Bishop a three or a
Knight takes a two so if you play a
knight Knight c6 and if I move my Queen
then she takes my night so I have to
play rook takes c6 and after Queen takes
c6 Knight takes a two is the point so if
she plays rook takes c2 and gets rid of
the past pawn I go night before and I'm
attacking all three major pieces so
that's why she played Queen take c2 and
I take c1 Queen take c1 and here my
original intention was rather boring
just to take on f4 and damage her pawn
structure but when I got to this
position I realized that my bishop was
definitely stronger than the knight and
my past eight pawns were pretty
dangerous type lady Farah and here she
was really worried so she spent up most
of her time and played g3 I played Queen
85 with the idea of a three because I
thought if I played a5 immediately she
might take on a five take take and my
remaining a pond is somehow not as
strong as my a for pun so I played Queen
a5 and I wanted to preserve the a pawn
and they're actually here I think if you
place Queen c6 I have a little I have a
few technical difficulties in the game I
was playing to take on e4 and then play
a three and if Queen c5 then I play
Queen e1 Czech followed by a two but I
missed she has just Queen c3 so if she
played Queen c6 I'd probably have to go
a three Queen takes a two and when in
exchange anyways but in this version her
pieces are more active so Queen a5 was
actually a kind of inaccuracy but she
played Queen a1 and I played rook b8 I
was bringing in my rook to support the a
pond and here I nailed the queen of down
on a1 and she was forced to go back but
actually I was kind of surprised I
couldn't find an immediate win because
somehow there's no direct way for me to
get the Queen out of 8-1 I played Bishop
before threatening Bishop c3 but she
played a knight C and ie 2 and
not just preventing bishops III but also
threatening nicey one and taking the a
pawn so that's why I played this move
Bishop d2 and dominating the night so if
now Knights the one that I will play
rugby one and if Queen takes a two she
loses a rule so seeing that she made a
waiting move played King g2 and here
once again I didn't see an immediate way
to win I'm actually my original idea was
if she if you if she didn't play King g2
and played some other move then I would
play Queen a4 and because rook takes D
to earth be one is a check she has to
play rook F one and then I would play
Queen c2 or rugby one and chase out the
Queen
so with Kim G - if I played the same
idea she would just take it and after
rippy one since it's not a check she can
just take on a two so I played queen a
queen d5 check and the point was if she
went back with king b1 then Queen b3
again it was my idea and so that's why
she played f3 and she is attacking my
Bishop on 85 here I think there was a
brilliant see if I went for rip b3 I
could sacrifice my Bishop and give mate
with this move g5 and if Queen takes a
two I play rugby six come around and
checkmate her but I wasn't looking for
all that stuff and I decided to play it
safe and I put my bishop back on a5 and
if she does nothing I will play Queen b3
Queen c2 and rugby one and if she did
something like she did well I still play
King b3 and the point is that after her
move king of - I played Bishop d2 and
after work do you want I could win in
probably a thousand ways maybe Queen c2
or if b1
but 23 is when I chose because it wins a
piece after King f1 I take and she has
to lose her knight and this one
immediately loses - pretty - so after
Queen III she resigned and that's how I
won the game
great win over the Women's World Chess
challenger roofing what is next up on
your chess calendar I think a couple of
small tournaments and then the spice Cup
in st. Louis again the spice cut very
prestigious tournament of course and
it's awesome because you know it's right
across the way from here so thank you
for your time Grand Master roofing Lee
hopefully tomorrow works out for you as
well and you finish strong
let's take a look with just one round
left the standings in group a Georg
Meyer and yarrow zero book are at the
top of Group A on Thursday September 14
yarrow zero book has white against Jew
in June while Jared Meyer has black
against roofing leak both of them are
playing opponents that have had
comparable performances this tournament
thus the only slight edge would be to
yarrow because he has the white pieces
it's a very slight edge now if both
Meyer and zero book lose look at the
players underneath them that can
capitalize daro spirits Alexandre
Shimano
Kovalev Jew and June a wonder Liang any
of them in a playoff situation could
take advantage however it's a slim
chance that both Meyer and Zahra book
will lose to let the four pointers in
and this is Group B round eight tattoo
of Abraham and congratulations today
defeating Akshat Chandra let's take a
look at the game and then I want to talk
to you more about this tournament and
how it's shaping up for you okay I
played up shot twice before once with
black and one with white first first
time I played I believe I had the white
pieces and he actually played the French
against me and he's been playing a lot
of different things lately so I wasn't
sure what to expect so if you place rook
air-five I already have some tactics I
can't
gone eight-six threatening mate he has
to take and I'm winning upon so the
question is where the rook is gonna go
so I thought the rook has to go to e8 to
protect it a Trank but he said he was
worried about Queenie foreign putting a
pawn on d5 which is which was my plan
and once I accomplish that
not sure if you should move okay let's
say he defends yeah and once I
accomplished that I'll be able to put a
bishop on c3 a rock on d1 and I'll save
by d5 fun and now my bishop is going to
be quite strong but I think this
position should still be okay it's not a
play group d5 which I mean it looks
threatening before because he's liking
my d4 pawn but unfortunately for him the
e-file is it's just mine to take and the
eighth-ranked is going to be a problem
and again he cannot move this f6 rogue
because h6 is hanging so it's it like
long-term he has good position but like
tactical in to dynamically think I have
a lot of initiative
so I played h3 so I don't know if a tree
is accurate I think doubling only file
is more accurate what I didn't like is I
didn't like this Queen c8 move which is
why I played h3 and now I thought he was
just gonna cut his pieces on the light
squares which I didn't like I don't
really have a queen so I played HT to
stop Quincy and I didn't really see you
good enough for him I thought maybe you
should try Queen afraid he played Knight
a5 and I thought even here maybe he
should just put a queen on d7 rook on f7
and just or even put a rock on f8 and
just defend the eighth-ranked and I'm
simply threatening rook e8 and this
position is very uncomfortable I didn't
say clear wind like I don't see clear
mate but I can like once I play rook e8
I mean there's a lot of tactics so the
rock on d5 is actually quiet misplaced
because in some position I can
like a rookie a rookie a 20-cent rookie
seven and then I guess I'd like me
so let's say I pass basically so I'm
just passing them off like if I do
something like this of course you cannot
take with the night because the queen is
hanging so if you do something like this
and now this rook is in trouble so he
played rook g6 so Queen f4 so here we're
actually both of us were in real time
trouble but I just I just think black
simply doesn't have moves because none
of his pieces can move the knight is
stuck cannot move it their paint the
rope just doesn't have any moves and the
rock on d5 is really miss players you
really wishes this route gonna fade
right now or something like that
so he played c6 so here I have a very
strong move of h4 I'm trying to go h5
and again his pieces are trapped so I
went G for his Knight doesn't have any
moves
this Knight is stuck so Bishop d8 the
idea is to play Knight h4 so I went to
Rock e6 so he cannot take because i-5 is
hanging now so I'm just winning a piece
so do you hmm so Queen f7 rook e8 and
Bishop g5 um so initially my idea here
was to play Knight e5 so 24 and I
thought this position should be winning
because I thought I can play a 4 and
then I realized this is a pin my rook is
hanging but I simply took and he took
with the rook so I thought he's gonna
take with the pawn and then I have Queen
f3 so I've been on that file so the
knight has to go back and I simply play
Queen d3 and once again like has the
problem that he doesn't have any moves
and I don't even have to have any media
thread it's just I cannot move anything
but I do have the threat of just
doubling on the eighth rank and then
there's going to be some problems
so this position is very tough so for
example if he plays here I can just
simply play rook e6 and black is
basically in a zigzag I'm starting to
win a piece I'm training to take on this
exchange everything on your six and take
on g8 and if you go here and describe
your point so this is this problem it
just doesn't have moves so you took with
the rook so I play King F 1 with g6 of
course I can take on f5 and be a piece
but I didn't want to like do give any
chances whatsoever so I thought to rock
the 8 I'm just gonna check meet him
so you please give 6 rookie 8 so now if
he moves to look I'm sorry if you move
the knight let's say Knight H for now I
simply have a check so if you block with
a piece it's made and if you block with
the pawn I'm winning
the Queen I thought this was very clean
so g5 so here he's just playing an
increment it doesn't have any times I
think it's just playing on inertia so
Queenie 4 and I mean rock just excellent
that doesn't make sense but like it's
completely busted because it's
threatening to win the ph8 and look at
fire rotate rate and have a many ways of
winning sum up a piece I've worked Jade
a hefty five so the game is just simply
over I think that's a pretty finish well
thank you you're welcome
anyway so this this tournament you're at
with one round left you are at minus two
I believe now because you're the lowest
seed that's not a big disappointment
there's not a lot to lose here how would
you assess your performance in this
tournament
so far it's been a very difficult
tournament for me it's because I played
the tool lowest rated players who are
still 24 hundredths and a half seven
gems and roll so I think the only time I
had a tournament when I had to play
seven James in a row
I play in world team for us and not
attempted players my flame that wasn't
working one so it's very hard because
when you're playing grandmasters
your weakness is really sure so they can
play lower rated players you know you
can get away with something so I've
found myself in pad positions like I can
really like I left so many ants and like
every game I'm realizing like so many
I'm games are lost I mean I've had some
wins I had some nice games so I think
I'm playing ok but it's been a really
tough tournament for me and even the win
over Alejandro must have been
emotionally tough describe how that was
beating a good friend of yours well I
played him several times last time we
played well last time I played I made a
drive but before that I was completely
winning against him and I ended up
losing so I mean this game like it was
nice to win that way like I had a really
question win but when you're playing
someone that's strong and they lose that
way you know they they just had a really
out date and I mean it it doesn't feel
good so who do you have tomorrow
probably this ok well good luck with
that tattoo event thank you joining me
let's take a look for the last time
before the last round the standings in
Group B Josh free Dell has Group B in
the palm of his hand all he has to do is
win on Thursday September 14 with black
against angel a rebus board number one
that's the one to watch and you can bet
that every other player in that room is
going to be watching that game now if he
doesn't win look at the players
underneath him
Alan peach it Alejandra Ramirez and
Antonio's Pavley Dee's these players
could all win outright without a playoff
situation this is also a very exciting
circumstance it all comes down to this
the final round on Thursday September 14
the games begin early at 11 a.m. to make
way for a potential playoff situation we
would have later in the
same day you can catch it all at chest
24 and US chest champs calm